Once he settled
comfortably with hips and
shoulders square and
wearing his helmet, they
begin taking
measurements, starting
with the height of his
head, critical for
aerodynamics and of his
sightline over the hood,
critical for safety.
The driver sits down,
gets out, gets back in
several times over as
the technicians measure
and make adjustments.
When it's all done, they
run the vacuum for
another four hours and
then let the foam cure
overnight. The driver
returns for a final 2 to
3 hour sitting, during
which the techs trim the
foam as closely as
possible to the contour
of his body onto this
dull surface.
They adhere positioning
targets, reflective dots
spaced four inches
apart, which create a
grid pattern over the
entire template.
The 3D laser scanner
reads these reflective
dots, which a computer
translates into a 3D
image.